you guys saw mark cuban bought a small a
small city right yeah what did he pay
for by the heat like four million
dollars okay let me let me read that
real quick and and you'll see where i'm
going with this marketing texas yeah
something like that he just decided to
buy this city mark cuban buys a small
town in texas just because cnn he just
bought the entire town of mustang texas
a blip on the map off i-45 with a
population of 21 people the reason cuban
said a buddy needed to sell it i don't
know what if anything i will do with it
cuban said mustang is pretty much a
77-acre blank canvas for cuban the town
was founded in the 1970s and et cetera
said there's nothing really crazy about
it right on why he bought this for four
million bucks but here's what i will
tell you
to argue my own point i just made to
argue my own point i just made this the
following
here's what i think
folks who have money ought to do here's
what i think folks who have money ought
to do
i think i think what would be very
interesting is the following america was
kind of founded on being a
country that you would come to that you
had to qualify to come here right you
went through what the whole uh uh
the island you would go to rikers
island not rikers
too
much
alice you'd go to ellis island and the
first question was what what value do
you bring to us yeah and you would say i
know how to sew i know how to do this i
know and they would say okay cool come
on here you're bringing value to america
right that was the right setup and then
it was what
what value do you bring who cares come
on you're a criminal totally fine bro
come on it's okay we welcome everybody
it's standards were dropped it's almost
like this img whatever the sports
program is they pay eighty-three
thousand dollars
in florida yeah where you go there and
your kid goes becomes one of the best
players and they said you know what
though you're rich pat send your kid
it's okay your lower understanding just
because of money right that's what
happened to america it dropped the
standards dramatically what i would be
very interested in is the following take
some of these guys like a uh uh who's
the guy that made five billion dollars
on a roth ira peter thiel take some of
these guys who bring their money
together and they say look let's put a
hundred billion dollars let's buy a
small country and the only people that
can come here you have to qualify and
the standards are so high and in our
constitution it states you have to only
bring value to come here who is john
galt
but but i think that's the direction
it's coming next if you get to the
tipping point that you piss off the
creators the creators always have an
option so what i'm saying to you is i
think this whole thing of majority
saying oh my gosh the government is so
good to me they're giving me so many
free things this is awesome what a great
noble of people i can just stay home and
kick in and just buy ethereum and
bitcoin and make money and play video
games these guys are the greatest people
i've ever seen in my life and they're
gonna say really really no problem you
want to do drugs did you hear what elon
musk said yesterday in an interview
about drugs did you guys hear about this
or no elon musk says drugs probably make
you age more if you can go a little bit
lower tesla elon musk was spoke out in
opposition to president joe biden's
economic signature package question need
for legislation that would support
electric car
adoption due to concerns government and
then he's talking and then eventually he
starts talking about drugs in this
interview so yes we're going in this
direction
of hey you should try this you know try
this drug try that drug try this truck i
think the creators
in the next five 10 15 years what mark
cuban did with 4 million bucks dude if
100 billion dollars people say we're
buying a country you want it it's 10
million dollars behind no problem i'm in
i'm fully in put 10 million dollars to
minimum 10 million buying to live in
this place let's go create and then we
go and then we start building our own
country i think do not be surprised if
in the next 5 10 15 years that takes
place it's called singapore and it
already existed and yeah yeah it was
exactly this concept yeah that's where
everyone is by the way there's been more
family offices open there than any other
place in the world medical corporations
exactly bloomberg new economy forum is
by the way that's the next iteration of
world economic forum that's kind of done
it's the bloomberg new economy forum it
just happened it was in singapore
everybody was there you know there's too
many jets and not enough hangars i mean
it's this type of thing is going on yeah
but have you seen what singapore looks
like by the way can you pull up
singapore
it used to be a swamp okay so so but but
this is you're talking about something
that's different from
uh imagine that as a swamp to that you
know all because of what you're talking
about but in this era the the power okay
the power is in in control of data
i mean data is what these guys want to
control like musk the cars are not the
issue here you know it's control it's
it's what can you grab that's where your
power comes from but we're talking about
the underclass you know in america there
was no nowadays it's like you just walk
across the border and get a social
security number and you're part of the
underclass
and elites love a huge underclass it's
kind of like when you go to mexico city
it's it's a it's a nice place if you're
an elite because you have a big wall
around your place and you have guards
you have all these things and it's not a
nice place if you're looking for
meritocracy for a place to to rise
feudalism it's very difficult but if
you're at the top it's nobody is going
to come and get you as long as you play
your cards right is good for the
plantation owner exactly and so what
you're talking about is is very
complicated because you have this
gigantic underclass that's kind of
waiting for the sweepstakes with crypto
you know the next coin that went up to a
penny is pancake coin you know and
everybody's like oh my friend had it i
should have bought it i mean this is
distraction and metaverse is distraction
but now you're talking about elite what
elites are going to do and they're not
going to advertise that you can come to
the compound i mean these guys are doing
this it's happening right now i mean
these guys are not sitting around in
kansas city in a subdivision i mean it's
it's it's i tell you i i will tell you
there is a way to
uh uh there is a way to
uh judge somebody that's gonna bring
that even is a not a millionaire not a
billionaire that's gonna bring value to
your town it's very easy to con to
decipher and process through that's not
that complicated what are you bringing
to the table so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]